while splash is a PG rated comedic romp
that generations of kids have seen and
enjoyed watching the movie as a grownup
brings the stories darker themes
swimming to the surface here's a look at
some things only adults notice in splash
splash is a romantic comedy and a fairy
tale that's driven by the enigmatic love
shared between a human and a mermaid but
as seen through an adult sighs one of
the most striking things about the movie
is how fast Tom Hanks character Allen
and the mermaid he dubs Madison fall
into a serious relationship after
rescuing Allen from what would have been
a fatal boat accident the first thing
Madison does is kiss him and when
Madison makes her way into the city and
finds Allen the two immediately start
making out Allen doesn't even know her
name
nor does Madison even speak English yet
before the two are sleeping together
it's true that stories of mermaids often
tell of a powerful magnetism that comes
with a siren song and presence and that
allure is perfectly captured on screen
by the stunning Daryl Hannah however
seeing this dynamic play out in a
pg-rated family movie might be a little
surprising to some there are a number of
cringe-worthy aspects of splash that you
might notice as an adult but Allen's
brother Freddie portrayed by John Candy
is probably the most obvious at the
beginning of the film a 10 year old
Freddie is shown looking up women's
skirts at a boat party then as an adult
he's pulling the same terrible stunt at
a wedding it's embarrassing when you
were 10
look works for me I stuck winnin another
typical Freddie moment is when he shows
up at the family business with a stack
of penthouse magazines because an erotic
letter he wrote was published in it he
then proceeds to hand out copies to all
his colleagues and customers Freddie
also lies to clients about Alan being a
wounded veteran of the Vietnam War and
later in the movie when Alan and Freddie
are trying to rescue Madison Freddie
says something inappropriate yet
effective in Swedish to fool the Swedish
speaking guard the reason Freddie knows
this phrase is because he's such a big
fan of Swedish adult entertainment with
so many provocative moments there's no
easy way for Freddie to explain away his
inexcusable behavior liberal I'm a
freewheeling dude as Alan and Madison
take a romantic stroll around New York
City they pass a beautiful fountain
featuring a mermaid sculpture Alan
stopped to admire it and Madison asks
him why he loves it so much she's hoping
he'll mention the mermaid and then she
can tell him the truth about herself
but Alan dimers and instead tells her
that the city is about to remove the
fountain along with the whole park to
make room for condos previously in the
film Alan introduced Madison to the
concept of gifts by giving her a
beautiful music box then the day after
their conversation in the park Alan
returns from work and discovers the huge
mermaid fountain in the center of his
apartment inspired by Alan's gift
Madison wanted to return the gesture
apparently she traded her necklace for
the fountain which immediately brings to
mind several questions first how did the
movers even get that fountain upstairs
with such a small dolly and some rope
second how has it not fallen through the
floor yet and third even in a fairy tale
New York City how does someone trade a
piece of jewelry for a landmark we'll
just have to take Alan's lead here and
enjoy the thought of this extraordinary
gift rather than the reality of it on
Madison's first day in Alan's apartment
she watches a commercial for
Bloomingdale's and decides to go
shopping when she meets Timmy the
doorman the only word she knows is
Bloomingdale's so he puts her in a cab
and sends her to the store when Alan
returns to find Madison gone he runs to
his doorman in a panic and the two have
a quick and surprising exchange
looking for a girl turning toward your
books Allen clarifies himself and tells
Timmy he's looking for the woman he
brought home earlier but only adults
would notice the subtext here Timmy
seems to have an illegal side hustle
going on this moment probably flies over
the heads of younger viewers but it's
just another example of how this
family-friendly movie is sprinkled with
adult focused humor in a desperate
attempt to prove that Madison is a
mermaid dr. Kornbluth played by Eugene
Levy runs around Manhattan and throws
water on women he mistakes for her horn
bluff finally gets close to the real
Madison and exposes her secret after a
gala for the American president
while a confused crowd gathers around
the frightened mermaid she's quickly
taken into custody military scientists
begin studying Madison keeping her in a
tank where they can monitor her behavior
in their lead-up to dissecting her all
of this adds to a pretty dark turn for
an 80s rom-com at this point dr.
Kornbluth begins regretting his role in
Madison's captured so he concocts an
absurd plan for alan and freddie to
impersonate swedish scientists on their
way to examine her the men have no
identification and the only Swedish
Freddy knows is from adult films but
they effortlessly get in anyway they
also manage to smuggle Madison out of
the military facility without being
discovered until the actual scientist
show up in 1984 the United States was in
the middle of the Cold War it would have
been virtually impossible to break into
a military medical facility without
serious credentials yet in the world of
splash it's surprisingly simple that was
easy
that was simple when Madison is forced
to return to her life under the sea
she asks Alan to come with her at first
he's excited about the idea of leaving
and coming back whenever he likes
unfortunately Madison quickly burst his
bubble saying that if they leave
together now he can never return in the
end Allen chooses Madison even though he
still doesn't know how to swim this begs
the question did Allen actually die at
the end of splash he's a human and he
can't breathe underwater
he's also suddenly swimming perfectly as
Madison shows him her world
mermaids are known for drowning the men
who fall in love with them so is this
actually Allen swimming away or is it
his spirit is that why he can never
return these are certainly questions
that young kids will not be asking but
it's easily the biggest thing that
adults might notice in the final moments
of splash however regardless of your age
it's a lot more fun to not overthink
this one and just for a little while
believe that fairytale endings are
actually possible check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about classic movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]